[Applause]
four times angela merkel led her party
into a general election four times she
won that election and using a leadership
style based firmly in the political
center
when the berlin wall fell chancellor
helmut call brought her into government
where she thrived and when a scandal
engulfed him she engineered his
departure with a ruthlessness which saw
her first become party leader and then
chancellor in 2005.
she was underestimated by her rivals
the rivals talked about the way and the
means they would come to power but
merkel followed the logic of party
politics
get power keep power and get your
opponents and rivals away the ensuing eu
debt crisis propelled her onto the
international stage where her star rose
as she helped broker bailouts for
europe's ailing economies and cemented
her position as a german leader the
world's presidents and prime ministers
wanted to be seen with
but it was her handling of another
crisis which would shake people's faith
in her when refugees from syria's civil
war began arriving on europe's doorstep
she opened germany's borders more than a
million came
increasing numbers of senior colleagues
in her own party openly disagreed with
her policy
her poll rating suffered and the
far-right populist anti-immigrant
alternative for germany party thrived
many wondered if merkel was becoming a
lame duck
but then came the coronavirus and as
infection and mortality rates rose
across europe so did mackel's resolve
one of you was pandering
europe's economy is badly shaken
fundamental human rights have had to be
temporarily massively restricted to an
extent unprecedented for our democracies
these are decisions that are among the
most difficult in my term as chancellor
her pragmatism this time meant agreeing
vast grants to ailing european economies
she was
brilliant in managing through all the
crisis
but again not in a very visionary way
there's hardly a project i could link to
angela merkel saying okay this is where
she actually implemented
whatever topic we're discussing actually
a great idea so it's much more that she
managed to
to get through all these crisis but
covid was the crisis she couldn't manage
her way through alone
in her last days as chancellor the
numbers of daily cases hit record highs
now she had to give way to the incoming
government leaders who vetoed her
proposed lockdown and as the new
parliament deliberates she is just a
spectator looking on as the man who
replaces her does so having styled
himself as a male miracle dominic kane
al jazeera berlin